[Music]
hello
today we are in islamabad capital of
pakistan
to talk to prime minister imran khan
since decades pakistan
and india are stuck in a tenth stand of
about the region
jammu and kashmir pakistan also
neighbors iran
now in a violent conflict with the
united states
and becoming the epicenter of an
increasingly
volatile middle east tensions facing
threats from
inside and outside what are mr khan's
plans
mr prime minister your job must be one
of the most complicated in the world
i mean there is your relationships with
the united states
there's china who really wants to invest
here but the more they invest
your relationships with the united
states might become even a little bit
more complicated than you have
iran afghanistan before you join
politics you have
had such a fantastic life why do you do
that to yourself
so a few questions let me start
firstly i came into politics because
i felt that pakistan has tremendous
potential
always had tremendous potential when we
were growing up
pakistan was the fastest growing country
in asia
pakistan was a role model for
development in the 60s
so we lost our way and my whole
objective of
coming into politics was that
we wanted pakistan to achieve its
potential and it has huge potential
now your first question that
we live in a tough neighborhood we have
issues
balancing act because we have for
instance saudi arabia which is
one of pakistan's greatest friends
always been a friend in need for us
then we have iran which is a neighbor
and we have always had good relationship
with iran so
the the the conflict between saudi
arabia
and iran is something which
which for for pakistan would be
disastrous if it
if it went into some sort of a military
conflict
so so we are trying our best to make
sure that uh
these two uh one neighbor and one friend
do not uh things do not deteriorate
amongst them things do not
actually lead to a conflict and as it is
this region cannot afford another
conflict
the other is afghanistan pakistan is
doing its best for peace in afghanistan
afghanistan is one country which has
suffered in the last 40 years
and just purely on a humanitarian basis
apart from afghanistan being our
neighbor
we pray for this uh peace still to take
place between the taliban and the
americans and the afghan government
so finally there would be peace there
the the biggest problem right now is
india
i'd like to catch up on that i mean we
were nearly facing a war last year and
ever since prime minister modi scrapped
this special status for indian
administrated kashmir last
august it's getting even more tense
what is your government doing or
planning to diffuse these tensions with
new delhi
look i was the first political leader to
warn the world about what has happened
in india
india has been taken over by an
extremist
a racially extremist exclusive
ideology which is called hindu
the the ideology stems from rss
rss was born in 1925 it
modeled it its inspiration was the nazi
party in germany
the founding fathers of rss
believed in the nazi ideology of uh
racial supreme superiority and just as
the nazi uh ideology was built on hatred
for
another minority similarly
the rss ideology is based on hatred for
muslims
and other minorities christians as well
so therefore i
warn the world that this is it
it is a tragedy for india
and i think for its neighbors that india
has been taken over by this rss ideology
which by the way three times was banned
in india as a terrorist organization
rss assassinated the great mahatma
gandhi
so a nuclear-armed country of 1.3
billion
people is in the hands of extremists and
so
not only are people of india going to
suffer and they are already suffering
their rights in india and their
demonstrations
but kashmir to be specific
8 million kashmiris now for over 5
months
are in a state of siege and it's because
of the rs
ideology which believes that only
india belongs to hindus other minorities
are inferior
what does it mean for you i mean how can
you handle that conflict do you try to
talk to maori
what are you doing well when when i
first became the prime minister i made
every effort
to talk to the indian government
prime minister narendra modi
i my first speech i said you come one
step towards us we'll come to towards
you
that we can resolve all our differences
through dialogue
uh but it soon uh transpired that
that there was a reason why india was
not responding
and the the reason was the rss ideology
and this then soon became evident uh
last year when on fifth august
they unilaterally annexed kashmir
kashmir is a disputed territory between
pakistan and india
uh in in the
several united nations resolutions from
70 years ago
not only uh call it a disputed territory
but the people of kashmir were given the
right by the international community by
the united nations
that they through a plebiscite they were
they should decide their own destiny
but prime minister khan there are many
pakistani people who also
say that the human rights situation in
the pakistani part of kashmir is also
not perfect
how do you answer to that well
this is very easy why don't we invite
anyone
anywhere in the world can come and see
the pakistan side of kashmir
and then they go and see the indian side
of kashmir
let them decide what is the difference
yeah but still like protests against the
assad kashmir administrations aren't
allowed in kashmir
so that's not really freedom of
expression either either isn't it
azad kashmir has free and fair elections
they select their own government
they run their own affairs like in any
government they will have problems
but as i repeat again why
why don't we invite all observers from
anywhere in the world they can go
to the pakistan side of kashmir and then
they go to the indian side of kashmir
they will not be allowed to go to the
indian side of kashmir
everything is sealed all their top
leadership is in jails in india
thousands of teenagers have been picked
up from their homes
and taken away there's no internet
facility there there's a total clamp
down
you cannot compare what is happening in
india to what is in
azad kashmir but let me stress that one
more time i mean you
you'd really take strong stance for the
freedom of the kashmir people
obviously on both sides uh and you do
that also in front of the united nations
don't you think your voice would be even
heard more and better
if like for example protests in kashmir
and the pakistani side would be also
allowed why not let me say
the the best thing is let the people of
kashmir decide
the people of pakistan kashmir and the
indian kashmir
let them decide what they want to do
pakistan is all
ready to give them the right of through
a referendum or a plebiscite
let them decide whether they want to
remain with pakistan or
whether they want to be independent
we're all for it
you're just coming back from kashmir i
mean there was a
horrible avalanche more than 90 people
as we know by now
got killed what is the situation there
right now
it's it's a climate change that's all i
can say
very strange thing this has happened uh
this sort of weather in
in kashmir was unexpected and in that
particular area where
most of the people went into these two
houses thinking that they were safe
and the avalanche when it came it just
took those two houses so that's where
the
tragedy was but unfortunately this is
climate change now
do you consider like some cross-border
age with
india in this specific field to help
people the most and the best there was
already cooperation because
on the borderline the pakistan
side the army was already cooperating
with the indian side
because i think there were some losses
on the other side too
but that's a good sign so it's possible
in in really a tricky situation that
both sides
work together of course in any
humanitarian issues we would work
together but the the issue right now
in the indian side of kashmir is
is not just a commission issue of
humanitarian
it's a huge humanitarian crisis over a
hundred thousand people
of kashmir the indian side kashmir have
been killed in the last 30 years
and not just that i mean the the clamp
down
and the since fifth august uh it now
this is
uh the whole world should realize for
five months the people of kashmir have
been
put under siege the schools are closed
they don't they can't lead a normal life
communications are cut off as i said
their
senior leadership was all in jail so
therefore
i really hope that the world would take
notice of this
pakistan cannot have normal relationship
if this disputed territory dispute
between pakistan and india
recognized by the united nations if they
have unilaterally next that area
how can pakistan start talking to them
right now do you think the world is
paying too little attention
i'm afraid and sadly
yes consider the sort of just the media
coverage of hong kong
you know demonstrations i mean hong kong
what two or three people i think i don't
think
more than that have died in kashmir the
tragedy of kashmir
what is happening and you can't compare
the two and why is that
why is that why do you think the world
is paying
so much more attention to the hong kong
protests regarding the
situation in kashmir well i think that
the western countries
unfortunately number one is the primary
consideration
are the markets it's commercial interest
india is a big market
so that's one reason why we see a very
lukewarm response
to what is going on and what is
happening to eight million people
let alone what is happening inside india
to the minorities
what this rss driven ideology is doing
with this
citizen registration act and this uh
citizenship
act which is blatantly against
the minorities specifically 200 million
muslims
i mean this is unheard of what they're
doing right now in india but
specifically on kashmir the silence of
the world is number one
because of commercial interest india
being a big market
and number two i think in the strategic
western mind india is supposed to be a
counter balance to china
and therefore you you see a completely
different approach to what is
the all this uh and i'm afraid this is
uh going to pose a threat not just to
pakistan and the neighboring countries
or or to the indian minorities
but eventually this will be a threat to
world peace
because remember if
if this goes wrong in other words this
rhetoric
of the indian army chief
saying that they they put claim on
pakistan side of kashmir too
and is saying something like if there
was a parliament resolution
then the india indian army was ready to
move to the pakistan
side then what would happen
the unthinkable would happen two
nuclear-armed countries would come face
to face
and that's why i even in the united
nations i went there
to the general assembly and i appealed
to the
u.n that you must intervene right now
before
things get out of hand what could what
could
europe and what could germany
specifically do in that regard
i think germany has a huge role german
germany is
is the strongest country in europe
and therefore the european union germany
can play a part in the
eu which is a big uh
you know one of apart from the us
eu is the other uh big block which uh
the world looks for upholding human
rights
so we we hope that germany plays its
part i spoke to
chancellor merkel and i tried to explain
to her everything about
what is happening in india and actually
she did make a statement
when she was in india saying that you
cannot have this
uh go on for unlimited period of time
with
8 million people are put put under siege
by 900
000 indian troops so she's she did
speak about it but i think uh and i hope
that germany will speak out against what
is happening
um mr prime minister you talked about
minorities your governments cut a poor
corridor
is a long indian seeks to visit a really
important place
of pilgrimage here in pakistan and you
got a lot of
applause for that do you think it can
help
to improve the relationship with india
you see uh
i have i've not understood that what was
the mindset
i mean uh no logical mind
would not go towards solving and i'm
talking about
indian leadership and pakistani
leadership
any logical mind would want to have
peace and solve our issues
through dialogue it's logical because
you know when you when you trade
we know in european union that once the
trades start between two countries
then the standard of living goes up in
both the countries
uh even if you suffer for an imbalance
for us
for a short time but eventually everyone
benefits from trade
so this is the what i i had in mind when
i spoke to
the indian prime minister when i first
won the elections
and the whole idea was that uh you know
to alleviate poverty in the subcontinent
the best thing would be for india and
pakistan to start trade
are you planning something for the hindu
community as well
so that they for example would be
allowed to have
a visa free travel to india to visit
their
places there at the moment it's it's
just a corridor kartharpur is just a
corridor
where they because it's one of the most
sacred in fact
it is the most sacred place for for for
the sikh community
and it was only four kilometers from the
border so we
thought that you know why should the
sick community not be able to visit it
from india or
anywhere else in the world and that
would mean that the hindu community also
it would be easier for them to go to
india as well on a long
you know in a bigger thinking and a
bigger picture do you working on that
um yes we would like that
but at the moment we have this tension
going on
you know there's a bombing on the line
of control right now between
in kashmir so there we have this
tense and as i said the indian army
chief just gave a threat in pakistan
that
they could annex pakistan side of
kashmir too so we have a
temporary problem but in the long run
and i hope a sane government comes to
india which is not
driven by this mad racist ideology
what would be best for the subcontinent
is if we can
live in harmony with each other and
trade with each other and of course
there's only one difference and that is
kashmir
and if that could be resolved according
to what the united nations security
resolution was
70 years ago talking about the
subcontinent it's such a beautiful part
of the world
i mean especially pakistan as well
wouldn't it be great if you could kind
of let
tourism blossom and get more people here
to visit these beautiful sites
we have we have we're opening up
pakistan for tourism
we have for 70 countries we have decided
to give them
visa on the airport so it's a big change
in pakistan
we have we're really opening up our
country for tourism pakistan is actually
one of the most
undiscovered uh
tourist tourism paradise in the world
there's
our northern areas up if you if people
like mountain tourism
i think there is no the most unique
place in the world
as far as mountain tourism go are the
northern areas
so what else are you going to do to
improve tourism or to
grow the the it's also an economical
branch right i mean
well for a start our security situation
has now
improved pakistan has uh
you know been the safest since since
2004
you know really trump problems in
pakistan started after 2004
when we joined the war on terrorism and
so pakistan
came in the eye of the storm and we lost
a lot of people 70
000 pakistanis died in this war but now
this
is the safest year after 2004 so we are
heading now towards
security in this country and that's why
as it is
tourism doubled in pakistan last year so
as it is
because of the secure environment we are
having a lot of tourists now
mr prime minister when we talk about
security issues we have to
talk about afghanistan what is the
current status of the afghan peace talks
as far as i know they were heading
towards a ceasefire
and we hope that this happens
because i repeat again afghanistan
is a great tragedy for 40 years
people of afghanistan have suffered
through conflict
and so what we are hoping is now the
taliban
american talk succeed and with the
new uh government and power of on
government
again of course president ghani being
re-elected
we hope that now there's some sort of a
peace agreement
which is apart from the people of
afghanistan the next country
that is desperate for that peace
agreement is pakistan
because it opens up opportunities for
trading
right up in central asia it becomes
an economic corridor for us uh trading
between if the
the the more peace returns to
afghanistan
the more people in in especially in our
kp
adjoining province to afghanistan will
benefit
so um as i said we are praying that
this works out this peace deal you
really were quite a big bit of a help
for the united states
how close is your connection to the
taliban right now
well pakistan has done its uh played his
part in the peace talks
we've encouraged the peace talks and
secondly also we have
um you know there was a hostage
situation so pakistan
played its part in uh getting the there
were three western hostages which are
two
which were released so we we are doing
our best and whatever influence
because remember there are 2.7 million
afghan refugees in pakistan
so whatever part we can play because of
still the
refugees and whatever linkages pakistan
has with the taliban
because remember pakistan was the
government that had recognized the
taliban government
which was there till 2001. so so we will
do our best
is india's increasing influence in
afghanistan
a threat for you how what do you make of
that it's
it's uh well any country
afghanistan is an independent country
and it can
have relationship with anyone our
problem was really when
pakistan our security forces felt
that india was instigating attacks into
pakistan through afghanistan
that was the main concern of pakistan
apart from that well it's a
india and afghanistan relationship is
between the two countries
but it it only affects us when
we feel that india uses afghanistan to
have terrorist attacks within pakistan
mr prime minister you were quite
critical about the reception of the
world
regarding kashmir and india when it
comes to
china and the vigors you are not really
very critical about this
issue why is that i mean you really
kind of like to stress the fact that
that you see yourself as a bridge
builder in the muslim world
why are you not more outspoken about the
situation of the rigors in china
well two reasons really number one you
cannot even the scale of what is
happening
next door in india you cannot compare
that to what has happened
what what is supposed to be happening to
the uruguay community in
in china i mean just look at the scale
eight million people in kashmir are in
an open prison
for five months so hence i speak about
that number two
200 million muslims right now in india
with the citizen act
what we fear is disenfranchisement of
these people
uh you know remember that in in 1935
when
the nazis started the pogrom against the
jews first they had the registration act
similarly in myanmar they first started
a registration act of muslims
and then started the ethic cleansing
from of the
rohingya muslims so this is the first
step and hence
that is my number one i mean it is the
scale of the problem is so huge
that's why i talk about it but there's a
second reason too
china has been a great friend to
pakistan
china has helped us in our most
difficult time again
because of with the crisis we inherited
the economic crisis
so the way we deal with china is that
when we talk about
things we talk about privately
we do not talk about things with china
in public right now because they're very
sensitive that's how they deal with
issues
very close question you know you knew
lady diana very well what do you make of
the current situation
uh in great britain with the royals what
would she have said
to what her youngest son is doing right
now
do you know what i you know i have so
many issues right now dealing in
pakistan it doesn't seem to be a that
huge issue if someone
i mean it's their life really it's how
they want to lead
why should people interfere in it would
you have understood it
i guess so i can't say i mean
frankly i haven't really gone that
deeply into a situation i think a young
couple want to
as far as i know want to lead their own
life
well it's up to them thank you very much